WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN THIS
GAME?
THE BIG GUYS DOMINATE A OPPORTU.
TWO.
>> IS THERE A MORE UNDERSTATED
PLAYER THAT WE'VE HAD FOR THE 2E
ODD-MAN RUSH.GAME.
BEEN ALL KINDS OF RUMORS FROM
IS ABLE TO ZOOT
ITAR SIDE.
MAKAR IN DEEP. IT THROUG HIGH. !
MOVES IT FORWARD AND HE GOES TO
THE BACKHAND.
TH
GREISS ON THE WRAPAROUND BY ALEX
SECOND.
AND IT SCREECHED PA POKE AT IT T
THERE.
HE DIDN'T GET A LOT ON IT.
T.
PLAYED THE MAN OFF. ZONE, M
RIGHT THERE.
THOSE ARE THE PLAYS THAT MOST
PLAYERS CANNOTOT
SAVED BY FRANCOUZ.OUT
THAT PUCK RICOCHETED OFF THE
ICE AND HE'S OFF THE POST AND
WIDE ANANO?
A MAN WHO
THEY LEAD 5-2.
LANDESKOG IS NOT GONNA BE HAPPY
WITH BACK BEHIND
FRANCOUZ AND IT GOES BETWEEN HIS
LEGS WITH 1.4 SE
>> OH,